hey guys we'll go back to TIF in case
now today's video it looks a little
different huh looks like I'm somewhere
else well we finally fixed our spare
office and now this will be the place
where I will film my videos now these
videos I've been promising you guys
since forever finally we're getting this
started and for our first video here in
this space Casey is gonna be doing my
makeup cuz you guys have been asking for
that video for a while so now we're here
to give it to you and let's bring up
Casey come on he's gonna be doing his
talk show oh yeah what should I call
this little segment thing of mine where
I film here I don't know are you ready
to to work your magic on this space here
yeah now I'm gonna go wash all this
makeup off and I'll see you guys in a
bit all right so my face is now all up
nice washed and clean and I put a little
hair band for you to get my hair out of
the way are you ready I'm actually
really nervous why are you nervous
ah because I don't know what you're
gonna do I don't know I'm gonna do an
amazing job I'm gonna turn you into the
ideal in my head or like that that
different I feel oh you are not no this
is the ideal right now without makeup
it's beautiful but out of all the
variations of makeup I've seen you wear
over the years that are definitely my
favorites and I'm gonna try and put all
my favorites into one thing okay but I
don't know we'll see
and let's see what we got instant age
rewind you don't need that that is
enough oh thank Co this thing okay I
broke it okay what do I do with this now
does getting your makeup don't feel like
a massage on your face no no especially
not the way you're doing it oh okay yes
no I feel like a massage it feels like
you're taking it on oh it should not be
this much oh yeah
extract from forehead apply to cheek
yeah usually the way girls do it to put
dots of makeup everywhere and then you
blend it in
[Music]
we're are using three fingers at a time
I hit three area it's the same time
smart this looks like not right oh
that's hilarious you just like it's like
your finger painting it's funny because
I could feel the uncertainty with every
touch um to my face don't judge me by my
touch
that looks pretty even okay the lighting
is helping you a lot see whoa you caked
it on that's part of my process if
there's anything about art that I know
is that there's a process to every art
form and this is a part of the KC jam
process what else are you gonna do KC
Chan I am going to do treatment makeup
eraser
mai-chan your eyeball you're making sure
that I never opened up my eyes ever
again cuz you're kicking makeup on my
eyelids oh sorry
okay that's good that's good enough of
that can you only put it on the side Oh
even it up you know girls usually also
we have to be mindful of the difference
of our face and then with our neck
like the color so usually we blend in
whatever face stuff that we're doing we
blend it in with our neck to make sure
it looks even it's still pretty close I
wouldn't know where I'm stressed about
that just yet I just tell you what us
girls do yes a lot of work
whoo Sorry Sorry Sorry Sorry that's also
part of my process there's this ping dab
just that my eye lashes into my no pay
no game
Oh clumped up but we yeah I got makeup
on my lashes it's part of the process I
don't like your process all right what's
next powder yes what are you used to I'm
assuming this one yes
oh you look less sweaty how do you like
doing makeup I don't like it I feel like
you're judging me with everything I do
I'm trying to help you that's why I'm
saying like I have this control freak in
me that I'm fighting cuz I'm like you're
not doing it right you're not doing that
so I'm not trying to let go oh you're
trying to shut me up okay got it and now
you can speak it looks pretty good
I think it looks pretty good are you
getting this light though because I
don't feel much action going on over
here
[Music]
I could see that they're all powdery is
that your eyelashes are like my favorite
thing about you your face like it's like
a physical attribute they like and I I
totally messed it up you're lucky I
don't curl my eyelashes cuz then if you
would have to curl my eyelashes I think
it's screwed I would burn them off wait
young Burnham you know what I do I've
seen my eyelash curlers that do heat up
but they work better
I don't know I mean you think they will
work better luckily I was born with a
very nice eyelashes I don't think deal
with that's the this is the smell you
smell like all the time when I kiss you
really cuz I just bought that and they
never wear it oh really this is the
makeup video people I see all the time
they always bring it right up to the
camera and go so you want to make the
videos I don't even I don't see a
difference okay keep fighting so much to
not tell you how to do it I don't see a
difference chef it [ __ ] I mean there's
the other bronzer too and then there's
also this I've never used this this is
like a color cheek stick but it's pretty
cool cuz that's a magnet this oh with
this one it has that thick thing and
then it has a brush on the bottom like
oh oh I've never used it I don't see a
difference okay I'm giving a ball that's
why I may be not a good product I don't
know don't listen to me
yeah it's a great product no I agree cuz
that's the reason why I don't use this
one anymore cuz I bought it and it's
like barely anything something and I'm
like it this I just showed you how to
pre-cut I wait but this is not what you
showed your brush in it
right you look like Jigglypuff or one of
the pokemons I look I think you have a
rash on your cheek now that's why you
don't go crazy with the blush alright
what's next you want to do the eyes next
you tell me I don't know warehouse is
liquid it's not liquid
who said it was liquid it's pencil
itself says liquid eyeliner no it's a
liquid pencil eyeliner good like the
pencil thick gel instead of like a
different color
okay I'm gonna poke your eye here we go
ready I'm Shane I'm a brush I feel
nervous no that's what I'm looking for
that's way say this is the safety head
okay so I know I'm saying I'm trying to
bite my tongue but just so you know
eyeliner is eyeliner mascara little ass
things you put on your eye you do it i
shadow first I'm gonna follow my process
is this awesome
did you just ask if this is mascara do
you know how mascara this is my Sierra
eyeshadows eye shadow oh this is aa
shadow just be careful with this one I
really like this palette okay me too
that's why I'm using it ready I shadow
what you're putting it on my under-eye I
don't know what just give it a go I just
get a big up trust me you gotta trust me
on this one
oh I can't I can't just you till death
do us part you can trust me I'm glad
this is a one-time video thing guys
I'm so good we're taking risks and to be
an artist you have to take risks there
we go that's sexy whoo looks like a
black eye is that I shadow I can't tell
I don't know your point I'm gonna try
not to look at the viewfinder anymore so
it can be surprised with the rest of
this I like this man I think the hardest
part about makeup is during the second
time on the other side of the face then
you like matching it to match it yeah
why is it so hard okay here we go I
think I'm off to a bad start
is that for your eyeball it looks like
it looks really painful you're actually
being really gentle yeah masterda never
late hand guys sexy I think I'm doing a
pretty good job
no I don't know I'm just trying to get
the lens I'm not looking at the
viewfinder I can't I can't look at
myself anymore I want to surprise myself
at this point yeah surprise yourself now
that we went dark over there let's blend
a separate color all right mmm thanks
what's next darling do you're done this
no you just want to go with smokey eye
that's the term smokey eye I knew I was
doing something right want some pink
they're gonna go for some Barbie all
right oh man mess up this monkey eye I
feel like I'm taking too big of a risk
right now this is gonna ruin me I'm
never working the industry ever again
okay I'm pretty sure you're not too
worried about that perfecting apply it
very subtly it will work
whoo okay Casey okay not mad at that got
to repeat the success of the first i/o
that's a lot let's go for the Kim K no I
don't think even can pay versus I don't
know we're doing something out right out
of Blade Runner house it reminds me of
yeah I could feel you're putting it on
me I brought two oh my
shimmery pink eyebrows that's the new
look yeah match this I don't want to
critic n the other side yeah I think
we're going for a sci-fi look now all
right I think we're good on the eye
shadow now we will do a little bit of
mascara that's that's the next one on
the list of things to do or eyeliner
eyeliner I think eyeliners next this one
twist just some uses them and you second
now oh you just pull it because yellow
the other one that was poignant it
wasn't working
all right how do I do this it's like
calligraphy just don't put my hold still
look up sir
[Music]
thank you
girls get is so close to the eyelid like
the actual thing you trust me hey not
too bad
did you usually put this on the bottom -
no but if I wanna Amy Winehouse okay you
can do it I'm just telling you I cuz you
ask me do you usually I said no oh we're
gonna see what TIFF looks like with
double eyeliner
all right kind of messed it up Dan yet I
could feel it don't do it bottom then
let's find out this is very tense
process oh I'm not doing a good job of
this whoa oh no eyeliner is not your
forte
let me just connect it on the edges
Egyptian style
yeah the wing look cuz I can't even do
the wing look oh you look like you're
crying in the rain dang it the crying in
the rain look you know the liquid
eyeliner on the bottom lid is very 80s
that's exactly the house going for how
did you know yeah shouldn't been the
bottom one I told you it doesn't go on
the bottom you see my catchphrase I told
you it's part of the process okay
mascara what's this one do that's
mascara okay so I'm looking that's like
this is like the sixth time that's what
I keep telling you and it's the only
piece the only item to it you keep
picking up asking what it is because
it's bright red and I like red the
problem I have with beauty products is
they don't tell you what it's for like
look nowhere on this thing that's the
same mascara that one I just rewrite it
what are you talking about mascara must
gotta butt up this thing as vidiians
doesn't in Spanish it was it's on the
back it's in the fine print why is it
not why is it not on the front where
like all this earlier like what is this
what is this
Oh mascara and this head right there
he's complaining it doesn't say so this
one I bought because I buy a lot of
or makeup and this one I was like oh
that says all-in-one like let me try it
out and then I bought it and then I
hated how tiny the bristles were so I
don't use it
what is this for you to thicken the eye
lashes all right this is gonna undo all
the clumpiness
of the other stuff you put on oh man so
good I don't have eyelash curlers you
would for sure pinch my skis oh sorry oh
sorry what you couldn't do it oh sorry
wait I don't know I'm trying to see if
it to working your knife does make it
one of those things where it once it's
on it's just a really subtle change but
it's like less is more kind of thing
that's the way I do my makeup I can't
tell a difference whenever a lot of
people nowadays it's like kick it on and
like it has to show and I don't know
it's last one video pop up on my feet or
it was like French makeup versus u.s.
makeup and I guess I apply my makeup
more like the French cuz they're really
subtle they're really light handed with
the amount of makeup that they put
within us it's like a contour it Kim
Caleb hey looks pretty good in a really
must the baby's kind of way we're going
for the drunken 80s look oh you can do
the bottom see I had I had bad
experience with the bottom half of the
eye so I was trying to avoid it but now
that you mentioned it maybe I should
there we go we're going for the the hot
mess of the 80s look yes hot mess your
wife hmm I'm on a date night I don't use
this thing okay so this I bought it
because I thought it was hilarious that
it's an actual eyebrow stamp Oh buddy
and I'm like no way does it match your
eyes I brought two it just has one
generic shape but it's actually not that
bad it's actually pretty close yours
but yeah so I bought it I think I only
use it maybe like twice but yeah pretty
much what you do is you grab the eyebrow
so this would be from my right and then
you press it on like a stamp and they
press it on go and do this or do you
want to just do eye brow powder let's
just do this Tudor how are you gonna
press it without putting that press hard
intimate or lightly that's a ton get the
alignment like look at the arch and look
at my art see the reason why I'm using
the stamp is because I want to avoid the
troll I look on you and I feel like I
would mess it up so bad your eyebrows
that would look like this is very more
taller than if you wanted to do the
brush really I don't just go for it like
okay I think we wanted to try a look I
told you
yeah like the couple strands of eyebrow
hair that goes straight up because this
eyebrow is just like that it's you know
I have no eggs I have two calyx here and
I have a cowlick right under your
eyebrow it's so weird
after this experience do you think it'll
appreciate girls and all that work that
they put into their face I do appreciate
it I think it looks great
all right there's also highlighting oh
yeah highlight so this is a highlighting
powder but it broke so I just put in
this little baggie there's also this
thing what's that one also a highlighter
oh no it's so much easier use this I
just don't have something to contour so
you're only highlighting
okay that's okay I'm a master at this
cuz I do see a lot of change
yeah in the light oh yeah see it I see
it before head come on the news chain
right that I dunno it's the opposite
areas of where you contour your clothes
but where you put it not it no it's not
blending you have a street pressure I
know when you put it like you put it
right on my chin we're supposed to go on
top of the chin I'm right I'm done
changing the game if you're the one that
you're freaking out over it to like oh
no I messed up that's a part of my
process I just don't question you
exactly lipliner oh this one actually
gives the instructions on how to open it
twist all my goodness anything with the
word liner in it I'm terrible at this so
it's this is like the one thing you
can't mess up on everything else no I'm
learning from experience down speaking
from experience that Glossop it now okay
two eyes of it I gotta get pursue your
career with make the artists to show my
clients under straddle your color my
clients understand my process don't
worry about this I don't know I'm an
acquaintance your client here also
oh my goodness you have a mustache
Thanks
a lipliner mustache every time I keep
messing up I go higher you ain't Kylie
Jenner lips she over lines her lips oh
really
I'm gonna try it no just do what you
gotta do you've experimented a lot
already
hey [ __ ] you here and I could feel how
caked on everything it's not any
different you know yeah if this was like
sports and this is makeup versus Casey I
want a rematch
I'm gonna go wash my face and dry again
no no bowls I'll take the El this time
or maybe I'm gonna come back Jake was
too much you're jiggling it though
you're gonna like it
yeah really pops your lips out but you
focus you always doing this make your
lips into it like that's my thinking
face it's a bubble in the face okay hey
not too bad on the lipstick looks pretty
good I don't know what you guys think
okay I'm gonna go get a mirror it's on
my vanity okay look this is what he did
guys how do you think you did
oh man I can already see like all of
everything eyeliner eyebrows you're how
do you feel about this first before you
say anything how do you feel I can
actually literally isolate the things I
don't like and the thing I do like what
do you like the one don't I overall I'm
actually pretty proud of myself I feel
like I did a pretty okay job for some
that doesn't do makeup
obviously but yeah I really messed up on
your eyes
here we go Oh oh my god you actually
yeah you're right you didn't do that bad
but whoa am i shiny and this thing it's
pretty shocking it just look like a
street yeah I don't like that straight
either no and then you were in the head
I get cheated it's like super like shape
this helped you a lot like the eyebrow I
know I don't look that bad yeah I
actually I'm really proud of the eye
shadow good when you were doing it I'm
like all the rules of eye shadow that I
know which is to put darkness on the
edge never like really over here but
then I see some girls do it I don't know
but from what I learned usually you put
dark on the corners and you put it here
which is kind of like oh okay I see what
you did but it doesn't look that bad
I'll try to go from dark to my cheek why
you're so pink I'm so shiny everywhere
too it's all like glistening whoa caked
on makeup yeah the forehead wasn't off
to a great start in the beginning I want
a rematch though I think I can do it
better the second time
yeah there's no concealer and my dark
circles are still there
hey it's a work in progress the work in
progress I wanna see you do it without
the staff though I feel like eyebrows
would have really showed really your
whole work
hey I lined it up pretty good though
yeah you did actually because the times
that I used it oh it would end up like
up here like I couldn't align it well
skills you're pretty good skills you're
so humble I love that about you
you never brag I love that you're just
so modest what's there not to love about
me absolutely nothing
No I gotta go see people and this too
bad get away I should like my eyebrows
oh that hurt actually itself mashed your
face into mine how do guys movies if you
like mmm I think when the guy has a face
like this they'd be like and they're
always like oh my god I was amazing I'm
dizzy alright guys thanks for watching
quesa my hubby put makeup on this face
here let us know what you guys thought
of KC's skills and his process and then
me I know I was trying so hard not to be
a control freak I was just like let it
go let it go but wait yeah so hope you
guys enjoyed the first video in our new
space for filming and yeah let us know
in the comments below what you guys
thought of this video and my daily
makeup routine video will be next and I
will finally show you guys how I do my
daily makeup and it's definitely not
like this and I'm not involved Annie
won't be here all right guys it's
brought down by
[Music]